After retesting a cheek swab at August, we changed a few supplements. One of my new ones
is clear dim. The first time I started it, I only took it for a week. I had nausea,
hot flashes, and genital yeast issues. Interesting. We've had, I think it's the same person
making these comments. I don't know, but multiple comments are people using dim and getting
these types of symptoms. What are these types of symptoms of? They're symptoms of dropping
estrogen levels. So nausea, hot flashes, genital yeast issues, urinary tract infection type things,
that is a symptom of lowered estrogen. That's the goal of dim. So you're purposely taking it
to lower your estrogen levels. So you could back off on your doses to help with that issue. You
could pulse it to help with that issue. But in reality, that's really what we're trying to accomplish
with it. I recently started again week or two ago, and I'm not having the hot flashes or nausea,
but I'm having reflux and yeast issues again. I would suggest the reflux has nothing to do with it.
The yeast, yes, it probably has to do with it, as well as joint pains in my hip and fingers. Yes,
that could have to do with lowered estrogen levels. So I would just pulse it even if you take it every
other day, if you take it, you know, for three days, off for three days, that's called pulsing or
supplement, something like that that you feel comfortable with. Should I continue the clear? Yep,
so I would continue to do that. One more question related to hormones. One of my cancer causes was
hormones, according to the testing. I was taking bioidentical progesterone before by diagnosis, but
have not since March of last year. Would you recommend progestin's essential oil, that's a young
levied oil, or progesterone cream? Or is it best to stay away from these with my breast cancer history?
I would not recommend those things. I would highly recommend you stay away from those things. Well,
I have an estrogen positive cancer, not progesterone positive cancer, because progesterone, so you're
taking this cream, you're taking progestin's, which has estrogen in it too, that's a topical
essential oil as well. You're getting progesterone absorbed through the skin and absorbs very readily,
you're increasing the progesterone in your body. That's what I would recommend if I want to increase
somebody's progesterone, which I used to use that a lot for different patients.
Thousands wheelies really seek cancer patients. We use that less, because if you have an estrogen
progesterone, or her two positive cancer, or even if you don't have that, you can,
you will increase your estrogen. Well, no, this is progesterone, not estrogen.
Excess progesterone is going to be stored in your fat cells. So excess hormones,
progesterone, testosterone, and estrogen gets stored in your fat cells. And then you have
enzyme called aroma taste that breaks down that hormone in your fat cells to the bad estrogens,
which you don't want to do. So you should not, you know, this is where women should not
take testosterone, either if they have a hormone driven cancer. Because excess testosterone will
be stored in the fat cells, and aroma taste will break it out into bad estrogen. Hence the term
auto-robotase inhibitor, and aroma taste inhibitor blocks the breakdown of any hormones
into bad estrogens. It helps eliminate all estrogens from your body. That's what an aroma taste
inhibitor does. It's blocking that whole pathway. So that is a normal pathway in your body.
Excess progesterone will be stored in fat cells and aroma ties into bad estrogens. You don't
let that happen, so no, you don't take that.